president biden addressing americans for
the first time since pulling all troops
out of afghanistan the president
praising his efforts despite weeks of
chaos violence on the deaths of 13
american service members
i believe
this is the right decision
a wise decision
and the best decision for america
i was not going to extend this forever
war that assumption
that the afghan government would be able
to hold on
for a period of time beyond military
drawdown
turned out not to be accurate let me be
clear
leaving august the 31st
is not due to an arbitrary deadline
it was designed to save american lives
and president biden making this bold
declaration on how the 20-year war ended
the extraordinary success of this
mission
was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats
and intelligence professionals
pete let's uh get your thoughts first i
know you were watching the speech
upstairs you can hear me a little bit a
little bit
uh i will say i'll start with the speech
ended he started by he ended by saying
the few we have a future that is safer
which anyone who's looking what's
happened right now knows is
fundamentally not true so everything you
walk back from that uh was
the last half of it was a straw man as
if we were debating about whether we
should get out of afghanistan or not
that litigation is a has been done for
quite some time and he also presented a
false choice of either you have to leave
or you have to escalate and and and
built around that strong men as well so
it
for me it was a lot of blaming i mean
who did he blame he spent he spent a
quarter of the speech blaming donald
trump for where he is and then blaming
u.s citizens for not doing enough to get
out of the country uh he i also go back
to where he started he talked about only
the u.s would have had the capacity to
do something of this size and scale and
emphasize the numbers time and time
again although we'll get to the numbers
of u.s citizens because there was
something very revealing there
to which i think a lot of americans
looked into their television screen and
said only the united states would have
had the capacity to not have to do it
this way there were so many decisions
that led us to this point that we
decision points we could have made and i
keep going back to the consensus point
that you made yesterday greg as if this
was a consensus for a extremely
successful mission
whitewashing over the entire reality of
how we got where we were to include the
new revelation that the taliban had
offered us to secure kabul we had given
the opportunity to secure kabul weeks
ago before the taliban entered and we
declined so there was no uh attrition uh
there was no contrition meaning there
was no recognition that mistakes were
made instead he doubled down on what i
believe is a false narrative
and a false choice there are a lot of
straw mans in there there's also this
call for number four
this is just about
a an observation and not just from here
at this table but from in the white
house briefing room about the tone of
the president watch
okay let's observed
he seemed angry at the beginning of the
speech today
who's he mad at
i would say i'll
give you a different assessment of what
i saw uh which is that he gave a
forceful assessment uh laid out a
forceful case to the american people as
to why it was time to wind down a
20-year war
that has
led to the loss of thousands of lives
and in his view and i think he made a
firm case of this it's not in our
national security interest to be on the
ground anymore um so there yeah there's
that and that
might be true hopefully uh is the case
so they don't have the capacity to do
that but the tone was strange it was
like it started and really came in hot
initially it's a it's um i don't you
know i always hated it when they would
mind read trump but i feel that the the
dramatic changes in biden
suggest that it's performance
all the time i mean the fact that he can
go this way go that way they get tired
it it it is as it is though that it's a
suit that is you don't think he's
sincere no i don't and i'll tell you why
because um that wasn't a speech it was a
bait and switch to pete's point
what they're trying to do is redefine
the outrage against the president as
directed against the decision to leave
and the achievement of the troops so
that if you are mad about this you're
actually scoring keeping scorn on the on
the on the troops when it's really
obvious and we talked about this no one
is upset with the troops and no one is
upset with the decision he he was with
the thing that kind of
uh you know talking about the casualties
of war he went through this
no one disputes the cost of war is
understood we're focused actually on the
cost of incompetence everybody
understands that war is hell we have
friends that are missing limbs we have
missing friends so when he goes through
that it's like no it's not about that
it's about your damned incompetence it's
like yes we wanted to go on the maiden
voyage of the titanic
we didn't expect you to hit the iceberg
right he's conflating these things and
he also conflated like
it was a weird situation for him to take
credit for this extraordinary success
while at the same time blaming trump so
he's got this weird thing he's got it
all backwards the decision that trump
made is correct the follow-through is
abysmal what he's doing is the opposite
he's saying the decision is bad but look
at what i did i really got us out of
this mess no you got us out of a mess
that you created the biggest airlift in
history is your way of papering over a
mission that you screwed up for reasons
that we can't begin to understand
because you've screwed up on every
decision point
call for number two if you would this is
president biden talking about his
predecessor if we have that
my predecessor the former president
signed an agreement with the taliban
to remove u.s troops by may the first
just months after i was inaugurated
it included no requirement that taliban
work out a cooperative governing
arrangement
with the afghan government
but it did authorize the release of 5
000 prisoners last year
including some of the taliban's top war
commanders
among those
who just took control of afghanistan
raul will give you the floor after that
he's trying to
i mean
obviously spread the blame he wants
trump to share some of the
responsibility to use the titanic
uh analogy
what he did was they hit the iceberg
right away
the titanic was was mortally injured but
then it sailed on and they did a pretty
good job of patching it up
you know this was as the national review
says a catastrophic success yet all of
the bad intelligence the most
horrific failure of intelligence maybe
except for the russians not knowing that
hitler was coming in uh in 1939. what
the supreme are you talking about i'm
talking about the
the intelligence in the beginning when
he he came in and did not know that the
afghan army would run
how could you not know the afghan army
would run
how could you be so confident
conversely that the afghan army would
fight that you would hang your entire
policy on the
expectation of a decent interval that
the afghan army would fight you'd get
people out in an orderly fashion and
then at some point the afghan army would
exhaust itself and the taliban would
ultimately win and it wouldn't blame
biden because it happened two years late
after he uh pulled the troops out so
what happened is he had that expectation
of the taliban
being confronted by the afghan army did
not happen then he
he had already uh
evacuated all the american troops had
the civilians so the most vulnerable
people had been left behind the warriors
had been shipped out then they had to
re-ship in other warriors to protect the
civilians so it was a real uh you know
was a massive massive screw-up that they
did a pretty good job of cleaning up by
the end but it doesn't undo
all of the horror that happened
initially the afghan military
the president spent a lot of time
reiterating that and i only can imagine
that one that he believes it and two it
probably pulls very well um and it has
been very offensive to a lot of people
who said well wait you left in the
middle of the night at bagram you didn't
even tell the afghan commander that you
were going i mean you took away the air
support they did melt away
and we are where we are katie you can
comment on that but also i just want to
play this for you in terms of
the issue about afghan girls this is
what biden said during the speech this
call for number three
we'll continue to support the afghan
people through diplomacy
international influence and humanitarian
aid we'll continue to push
for regional diplomacy engagement to
prevent violence and instability
we'll continue to speak out for the
basic rights of the afghan people
especially women and girls as we speak
out for women and girls all around the
globe
that is also probably an issue where
they're seen again from the feedback
from their twitter feeds from their
friends and from the polling that that's
an issue
it's a really naive point of view i know
that they're trying to clean this up and
figure out some kind of solution to this
disaster they've created
by you know there's dispute about what
the military general said and did not
say a number of them would say that they
told the president including a number of
u.s senators that the afghan army was
not prepared that's also part of this
big question about being in afghanistan
for 20 years and this lie that was
propped up that the afghan army was
capable of fighting off the military but
in terms of moving forward with
diplomacy when it comes to talking to
the taliban through diplomatic channels
that aren't even in afghanistan they're
in another country
it's just completely opposite of the
reality on the ground they are hanging
people from our helicopters we have
video of the taliban going door to door
to execute translators and interpreters
who helped us
women are at the very bottom of the list
when it comes to especially girls when
it comes to rights in afghanistan i was
talking to a marine friend today who
said those a lot of the girls are
probably being sold off to men as we
speak we know that as a taliban was
coming through all these villages they
were taking a number of women from their
families and forcing them to get married
including of course underage girls so
this idea that they can talk their way
out of this in terms of diplomacy now
it's it's just a dishonest way of
looking at it i think broadly speaking
as we move forward with this
the administration talks a lot about
diplomacy in a number of areas well
diplomacy is the way that we deal with
the nuclear iran diplomacy is the way
that we deal with china and russia
without these conditions that we've seen
and
i think the future for those girls but
also the future of our foreign policy
and the safety of america is at stake if
they're going to pin it on talking to
people rather than having some kind of
force behind their words hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else